[Applause]
[Music]
n
[Applause]
you give us a summary of your
educational background or your health
care education experience Mr wal you
recognized my experience in healthcare
your educational background I'm just
curious you you you you testified as to
a lot of your own research I'm curious
for what purpose you do that and what
background you have to qualifies you to
speak to that well my background that
qualifies me to speak to this is that
I'm a human being with a brain and
common sense and I have a soul and so
therefore I think it's a really bad idea
to chemically castrate children that is
my experience um also I I did now it's
true I didn't I didn't go to college but
I did go to school long enough to learn
how to read so I can read the data for
myself and that's exactly what I've done
R Clemens here and for what purpose do
you um conduct your research and use
this brain of yours Mr Walsh you
recognized I use it for the purpose of
trying to protect children from being
castrated and mutilated that's one of
the things I try to do you don't use it
thank you Mr chairman you don't use it
to get clicks on your let publication
well are you using it right now to try
to get clicks with this
interaction on no I I I I I I really
like the idea of getting U of of drawing
attention to the fact that this is
happening to children I know you seem to
find it very amusing I
[Applause]
don't want to thank the governor and the
uh lawmakers here Mississippi who have
done the right and necessary Thing by
Banning the horrific medical abuse of
children I'm extremely encouraged to not
only see this law being past but to see
the national movement uh that we have
been able to build pushing back against
the gender ideology Madness that has a
strangle hold on our society uh and on
our children for far too
long the reality uh is that this is not
a difficult issue as the governor's
already covered it's quite
straightforward in fact if we lived in a
sane Society run by sane people we would
all be able to agree on this point the
question of whether it's ever okay to
castrate and sterilize and mutilate a
child um would be answered in one loud
and unified voice saying without
hesitation not only no but hell no that
is how all normal Common Sense decent
Americans answer the question and they
don't have to think about
[Applause]
it
this is an important question you said
you're an EMT yes I am okay if you're
responding you're responding to a health
emergency biological male somebody with
a penis is uh is having a medical
emergency and they say to you um I think
I'm having a
miscarriage would you would you check
them to see if they're having a m would
you consider that a possibility for
them
look no but that's because some people
don't have body
parts doesn't mean they're not a woman
okay sounds like we've established there
are some people who in principle can get
pregnant and there are some people who
can't so there's two categories
otherwise known as binary lots of Wom
can't get pregnant either yeah but
they're still of the nature to get
pregnant the only reason but they can't
get pregnant yes truth matters right it
it does that's what I'm trying to
explain to you truth matters and they
can't get pregnant that's the truth so
how are they still woman because they
are for for this for the same reason for
the for the same reason that I that I
can rightly say that human beings have
two legs and if a person is born with
only one leg that doesn't call into
question the statement that human beings
have two legs okay a person being born
with one leg doesn't mean that now legs
are on a spectrum and we can't say we
can't say anything at all about how many
legs a person has who knows they could
have they could be a centipede you know
they could have they could have a
hundred legs no we know human beings
have two legs if a human is born without
two legs something went wrong they were
supposed to have that second leg
something went went wrong if you if you
if you meet a person on the street it
only has one leg maybe maybe they had an
accident maybe they were in war maybe
maybe something you know maybe they were
in a car accident maybe they had cancer
a leg was cut off but you know that
something went wrong because of the by
their nature they're supposed to have
two legs same thing for a woman a woman
by her nature can get pregnant a man by
his nature never can so if you meet a
woman of childbearing age say she's 28
years old and she can't get pregnant you
know automatically that something has
gone wrong and she can go to the doctor
and find out what that thing is even if
they can't fix it so that proves that
women by their nature can get pregnant
because the simple fact that she can't
shows you that there's something wrong
this is what is known as the exception
that proves the rule whereas if a male
with a penis can't get pregnant no
doctor on Earth is going to run tests to
see what's wrong with him because they
already know it's that he's a male and
there's only male and female those who
get pregnant and those who
can
so that's it
that's
[Applause]
let's just try some stuff let's just see
what you've got okay so let's just start
very very simple today and we'll just
hold this Rhythm nice and tight okay
it's kind of a this thing you're doing
nope it's not front to back it's a
really side to side this what you're
doing you could mirror me actually you
know just like when you say mirror you
mean right like if if I if you were
looking at a mirror and I was looked
like you you want me to look at you the
mirror and then do what make it look
just like I'm doing but imagine I'll do
it bigger so if that isn't clear I mean
just out to the side it's just a step
out to the side yeah I think that was it
right there did you see what I did I I
did see that um that's not to the side
at all so well it depends on where
you're standing it's someone's side uh
it's going great so far I think you know
professional dancing I always say it's a
little bit like uh riding a bike and uh
you got to take some practice to learn
how to do it and then if you're not
doing it for a while you just got to
sort of shake the rust off and and get
back into the swing of things you know
what let's can I can I give you a note
sure yeah uh your instructions a little
unclear and I find that in dance it's
it's better to be very clear about what
you're saying
okay I've never seen a more
uncoordinated person in my entire
[Applause]
life from the moment she decided to live
her truth Ryan Webb knew she was in the
fight of her life living under the
oppression of heteronormative Standards
is considered business as usual to most
women but Ryan faced a different
learning curve many of the everyday
experiences of women were new to her
because until a few months ago this
lesbian woman of color identified as a
cisgender white man Ryan knew her
stunning bravery would make her a Target
but she never anticipated the amount of
hate she would face from her new
community
[Music]
this is a big moment for Ryan Webb
agreeing to an interview after revealing
her identity as a transgender lesbian of
color requires a different sort of
Bravery than we normally see in the
political world what is it like to be so
brave well you know I've never really
looked at myself as being brave um you
know I just simply uh declare how I see
myself and my um own expression of my
own gender identity and uh I didn't look
at it as being brave now I've been told
by others uh that it is brave and U for
those people I appreciate that but you
know I was a immune to to seeing it from
that
perspective